[Music]
alex you put that gun down right now or
nobody's going to unban you youtube's
how is youtube going to unban you when
you have a gun out
on your desk right now calm down as your
media buyer i have to
i have to advise you you can't be doing
this right you can't be doing this
hang on hang on alex one sec i gotta all
right i gotta leave
[Music]
sorry about that boys money's getting a
little tight since uh we bought the 10
million dollar studio
cash flow is not flowing in quite like i
thought uh
i guess i went a little ambitious with
this crazy studio so i apologize but
picking up some extra shifts
uh you know don't hate a guy for where
he works please
guys today i want to talk about
something that has nothing to do with
old jones
today i want to talk about jeff bezos
and the people taking advantage
ladies and gentlemen welcome to just one
scam
that's what i'm titling this video today
we're talking about just one dime
which is a company selling another
amazon automation course
so we're gonna decide should you invest
your money in this course how should you
think about this course guys
now why am i qualified to tell you that
right
uh you know am i some business expert
right i mean you decide
you decide it's just basically me
amazon and dan lok the top three
businessmen of our era
and uh yeah so i am qualified to talk
about it in case you're wondering
absolutely have very serious business
skills that are not a joke
but we're just going to talk about
common sense risk management because let
me tell you guys
everything this guy does is something
that i like to call
risk for thee none for me right
you want to stay away from these people
these people want to settle you with all
the problems if anything goes
upside down right because if investments
go well everyone's happy
obviously sometimes investments go well
sometimes
they don't now what happens when things
go sideways the people who are in steven
mayer's course if you saw my last video
on amazon automation
this guy ran off with 12 million what
are those people going to do
right the downside happened what are
they going to do well you might say
stephen they'll just sue
yeah guess what steven mayer is going to
do he's going to defend himself
with the money that they paid him
they're in a lose-lose situation they
don't have any money because they
already paid it to the scam
and now what are they going to do
they're going to try to get it back how
he's gonna fight him with
their own money so that's what you guys
have to think about
what happens when things go bad pay
attention to this guys
because uh this guy's gonna pretend like
they're not like the other gurus they're
different
let's listen in we will not sacrifice
our credibility for money
it takes years to build the credibility
we have compared to all the so-called
gurus out there
all right stop right there these people
need to stop saying
i'm not like those other guys i'm
totally different they all say
that right they all say that who claim
amazon automation and all they want is
the upfront feed then they'll give a
crap about you
you you can lose your reputation in five
minutes but let's just start with that
right
okay no high fees high fees upfront
scam because they're just trying to run
away with your the high fees well let's
see
what did steven mayer charge i think it
was like 30 000 so what's this guy
charging he must be charging a lot less
right
it is 10 000 fee per product
okay that does not include the cost of
the product you have to pay
ten thousand dollars per product and you
have to start with
three so it's thirty thousand dollars so
your minimum upfront investment is
thirty thousand no less
so you just criticize people with high
fees because you're like oh yeah
it they're just gonna run away and they
don't care about you but then
you're doing the exact same thing but
maybe i just don't understand
how much money you're gonna be making i
mean you must be ballin if you're gonna
put in 30k
minimum plus product costs maybe another
10k
each put you at 60k all in so you must
must be making a lot of money how much
money are you making seth here a
conservative roi we've gone through the
numbers so many times
a conservative roi within 12 months is
200 percent
200 percent interesting
okay okay seth i'm listening show me any
real estate
any stocks anyone out there even for
angel investors
who get an roi like that with this low
of a risk
now what's he basing this off of he says
he ran the numbers right what's he
basing this off of i mean is he making a
guarantee
seth can you give me a guarantee no okay
running the numbers your minimum roi is
around two hundred percent
minimum is that not a guarantee
wait does that sound like a guarantee to
you guys running the numbers your
minimum roi
is around 200 percent what number
numbers
your minimum what numbers hey what
numbers
running the numbers your minimum roi is
around 200 percent
minimum 500 percent a thousand percent
like that's minimum within a year okay
which is insane
that is insane compare that to where are
you getting that from though
running the numbers additionally
additionally the chances of us failing
at a product are so ridiculously slim
it's not even funny
for every 100 products i launch three of
them are not as profitable as i hoped
three so that puts you in a pretty
ridiculously good
case now let's just say worst case
scenario we've launched three one of
them fails you still make money why
because the success of the two more than
makes up for the loss of the one
but seth that's not the worst case baby
hey am i crazy or is the worst case
scenario that
three of them fail all three and then
you're left with nothing
worst case scenario we've launched three
one of them fails
it's just not the worst case scenario
and like
so are you giving a money-back guarantee
are you so confident that you're giving
a money-back guarantee
uh seth can you give me a guarantee no
so all of that's annoying
but that's not what really pissed me off
this is but that's just the beginning of
the fees let me explain all of them to
you talk about transparency
here we go 15 of
total sales revenue due every three
months goes to us
sales revenue boys he's taking 15 of
your
sales revenue now explain why we don't
do profit and it's actually in your
favor it may not seem like that
oh let's watch him do that mental
gymnastics again dude it's like watching
a gold medalist on the floor
now explain why we don't do profit and
it's actually in your favor it may not
seem like that i will explain that in a
minute
okay did you guys just hear that so not
only is he charging 30 000
right this guy he says 200 minimum roi
but if it doesn't happen it's not on me
then he goes okay i'm charging you 15
of your revenue meaning if you're making
no money
but you made a hundred thousand dollars
in sales but you spent it all on product
and margins and
all this kind of stuff ppc guess what
you still have to pay him 15 000
that's right gentlemen seth wants 15 of
your money even if you're making
no money at all and he says that's in
your favor he goes i was gonna do profit
but then i decided it's in your favor
now
watch this boys this stuff drives me
crazy uh
how do you justify the 15 revenue share
this seems high is this negotiable no it
is not negotiable let me explain why
we've been through this enough to know
let me just give you an example when we
first started this program we had the
idea
of doing a 30 net profit share and i
know up front that sounds better because
it is better because we don't make money
unless you make money it's a
terrible decision either way 30 it's way
too much your profits but okay it's it's
better
and i get that and that was my original
goal but the more we did it the more i
realized this is a problem let me give
an example
let's say we sell a hundred thousand
dollars worth of these
let's just say your profit was a hundred
thousand to keep it simple
when did we get our 30 000 because that
back then it was 30 000 net
if we get it now there's a problem
because that means you have less money
to buy the next batch
which means your per unit cost will be
greater which means your margins will be
thinner
wait stop he says i can't take away from
your profits because then you wouldn't
have enough money to invest
seth you beautiful idiot do you not
understand
that if you take away from the sales
revenue their margins will also be
thinner
i mean i don't know if this guy's
willfully well i know it's willfully
he's just
he knows that taking away from revenues
way worse
for the customer but way better for him
and he knows that
the margins are going to be affected
either way
and his whole problem of when do we take
the money well the same question applies
to when you take sales revenue when you
take it at the beginning before
someone's profitable
you could just replace exactly what he
said with sales revenue it would make
just as much sense
all of this is a big fat distraction
from the truth which is that there's no
good reason for him to take from your
sales revenue
zero but he wants to take from it anyway
because it makes him
more say it with me say it with me money
it makes him more money and he likes
that like seriously it's so funny
listening to this guy really struggle
with the concept
because he's basically saying oh yeah i
couldn't fathom taking away from your
profits that would be unfair
i mean how could i do that to you when
he's planning to take away from your
sales
revenue he could just do the same thing
with the profits
doesn't make any sense again
everything's for him to win
even if he doesn't do his job even if
seth sethi boy
you know if everything goes south
because he screws up your store
does he lose does he not make his cash
flow no
he still makes it baby and it's funny
because this is the guy who's saying 200
minimum roi
it is we ran a whole bunch of numbers oh
my god seth enough with the numbers sir
and we are airing on the side of you
making more than if it was a 30
net margin come on dude oh
anyway let's go back and we are airing
on the side of you
making more than if it was a 30 net
margin
you cannot believe that there's no way
you believe that
it airs on that side we've run it a
hundred times every way
how how have you read it 100 times 100
different ways
listen it's actually very simple all
right if you charge
15 sales revenue versus 30
profit there's only one condition in
which
30 net profit is worse for the customer
than 15
net revenue you want to know what it is
here's what it is if your profit margins
are over 50 which is
great for the customer they're making
money they're happy
then it's better for them if you're
taking 30 revenue so if it dips below
that let's say it gets to 30
right 30 profit margins guess what seth
still takes his 15
cut and now your profits have been half
he's taking an effective
50 cut of your profits so guess who it
benefits again
again this guy all the while he's trying
to
dupe you into believing that you're
gonna be making more money
if you go this way look at him i ran it
a hundred different ways oh we've done
it every way
and we are airing on the side of you
making more than if it was a 30
net margin it airs on that side we've
run it a hundred times every way
he's done it every way guys he doesn't
understand how the math works any other
way it doesn't make any sense
guys you have to understand that these
people are not your friend
they're not doing it for the good of
humanity right if they wanted to scale
up their business this guy's all about
scaling up his business
then go take out a loan
that's what it's called it's called a
loan think about the following facts
okay
he's saying that you're virtually no
risk right because
97 of his products succeed they're just
as profitable
as he thought they were and he's also
saying you have a minimum roi
of 200 right so that means that he could
do the same thing with the store of his
own make 200 on his money
so let's say he goes out to a bank right
he goes out to a bank
takes out a gigantic loan on 20 interest
if it's a minimum
roi of 200 that's no big deal right
because he's still making money he's
making
all of the profit instead what he's
saying hey i thought it was a better
idea
if i partner with you guys partner with
you small investors
where you take the majority of the cut
that doesn't make any sense hold on i
just want to add this part in i'm
editing this in post because
i i was watching the whole thing again
and i wanted to say one thing that he
this guy does right okay
which is that he says that if you don't
have the money don't join
i don't want you sending me the last
pieces of money you have and going broke
don't do it i criticize gurus all the
time about this
they always try to get everybody in this
guy he says if you don't have the money
don't join
i do like that respect for that i think
it's a terrible
investment opportunity that's just my
opinion i think this guy's protected
himself from
every single downside all the while
telling you that you need to risk every
penny
okay that's what he's doing but i'll say
that
at least he's not targeting poor people
so for that you get a coffeezilla one
star
the thing is guys is with all of these
programs you have to be thinking what if
it goes wrong what if this guy
who seems so charming he's smiling at me
saying what a good guy he is saying how
much he cares about me i care about you
buddy
you got to think what if this guy is
lying to you what if he's not telling
you the truth what's your downside
they stick you with all the risk they
stick you with all the problems they
pretend to be so confident in their
courses
but at the end of the day when you dig
down can you get your money back
no baby no if they fail that's on you
even if they kind of flounder that's
also on you because they'll take your
sales revenue dude what a joke anyway
this is your daily reminder to not fall
for the idiots call the clowns out
and as always don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
comes along